el pulso de jair bolsonaro con el
parlamento y la corte suprema parece
haber terminado con un cambio radical en
su discurso bolsonaro usó un tono
conciliador con los órganos federales y
también con los medios de comunicación
blanco habitual de sus ataques que sería
de nuestro brasil sin la cámara de
diputados- y sin el senado cámara
y tal vez porque el 11 y por qué no si
nuestro querido tribunal supremo le
mostré bona ofrecer a nuestra libertad
nuestra libertad de prensa con todos sus
defectos debe persistir y persistir el
primer revés tuvo lugar el día de la
independencia cuando el mandatario de
ultraderecha encabezó masivas protestas
que pedían la destitución de los
magistrados del supremo e incluso la
intervención militar en el país un
discurso que frenó en seco su ataque a
las instituciones desató manifestaciones
tanto entre sus detractores como entre
muchos de sus votantes decepcionados
estamos protestando en contra de un
presidente que traicionó todo el
discurso de su campaña y que hoy va en
contra de todo lo que dijo que haría es
un corrupto enchufó a miembros de su
familia roba el dinero del país entero
robo vacunas negó la ciencia
y
yo creo que hoy es un día de fuera o el
sónar o independientemente de izquierda
de derecha de centro hoy se trata de
mucho más de lo que uno sea partidario
se trata de la humanidad yo hoy estoy
aquí por la humanidad dos días después
de las masivas protestas del día de la
independencia
bolsonaro decidió publicar una carta en
la que pedía disculpas e instaba a la
armonía una armonía que muchos reclaman
en un país fuertemente polarizado de
cara a las elecciones de 2022